TO THE MEDIA.
NOW, THE QUESTION IS THAT SINCE
McCABE COULD FACE CRIMINAL
CHARGES, IS HE GOING TO FLIP?
WILL HE COOPERATE AGAINST THE
COMEY?
JOINING US NOW WITH A REACTION,
TWO OF THE LAWMAKERS, MATT GATES
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING WITH US
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING WITH U
US.
TO ME, THIS HAS BEEN A LONG TIME
BUILDING.
THIS HAS BEEN A LONG TIME
COMING.
SO OFTEN, WE HEAR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAY THAT IT IS
A PROCESS, IF I GET A REFERRAL,
I WILL LOOK INTO IT.
THEY HAVE NOW NOT ONLY THE
REFERRAL ABOUT THE SPECIFIC LAWS
THAT YOU BELIEVE AND I BELIEVE
WERE VIOLATED IN EACH CASE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SEAN.
WE HAVE THIS GUY, AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE LIKE HIM KNOW
THAT THESE -- THIS IS
INFORMATION THAT CONGRESS HAS
DEVELOPED.
IT HAS BEEN IN THE PUBLIC
SQUARE, AND SENT TO FOCUS ON
THIS STUFF.
COMEY, HE IS OUT ON THIS BOOK TO
HER -- HE DID NOT EXONERATE HILR
HER -- HE DID NOT EXONERATE HILY
UNTIL AFTER THE INTERVIEW, WHEN
WE KNOW THAT HE EXONERATED HER
TWO MONTHS BEFORE WITH THE MEMO.
THEN YOU LOOK AT SOMEBODY LIKE
ANDREW McCABE.
HE RUSHED INTO PROSECUTE MICHAEL
FLYNN.
THEY WENT IN, INTERVIEWED HIM,
PROSECUTED HIM FOR FALSE
STATEMENTS.
McCABE LIED TO THE FBI.
IT IS DOCUMENTED NOW.
IS THERE A DIFFERENT SET OF
RULES FOR McCABE?
THIS IS ALL ABOUT EQUAL
APPLICATION OF THE LAW.
>> Sean: WELL, THINK ABOUT
THIS, WHEN MEGHAN McCAIN
ACTUALLY ASKED COMEY TODAY ABOUT
HIS LIFE.
YOU CAN STILL LIE AND BE A GOOD
PERSON.
WAIT A MINUTE.
DOES THAT APPLY TO
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN, WHO WAS
CHARGED WITH LYING TO THE FBI?
CONGRESSMAN GATES.
>> SEAN IF LIES WERE MUSIC IT,
JAMES COMEY WOULD BE BEETHOVEN.
BUT WHEN YOU LIE TO CONGRESS, IT
IS A CRIME.
A CRIME APPEARED AND WHEN YOU
ALLOW YOUR PERSONAL POLITICS TO
DICTATE THE OUTCOME OF AN
INVESTIGATION BEFORE EVEN
CONDUCTING THE INVESTIGATION IN
EARNEST, THAT COULD BE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
AND SO IN CONGRESS, WE DID NOT
JUST WANT TO SIT AROUND AND HOPE
THAT JEFF SESSIONS AND OTHERS
WOULD SERIOUSLY LOOK INTO THESE
MATTERS.
WE WANTED TO SPECIFICALLY DETAIL
THE VIOLATIONS OF LAW AND THEN
DEMAND ACTION FROM OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL BECAUSE WE
CANNOT ALLOW THIS TO STAND.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI, JAMES
COMEY, FIRED, THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR, ANDREW McCABE,
FIRED.
IT IS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> Sean: AND THIS IS A BIG
PROBLEM.
I KNOW THAT IT HAS BEEN OVER A
YEAR.
WE ARE WAITING FOR THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO FINISH HIS REPORT ON
THE CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION,
BUT HERE'S WHAT WE DO NOW.
HE DOESN'T HAVE PROSECUTORIAL
POWERS.
NOW, I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL PUT THIS OTHER
PERSON IN PLACE AND SUPPOSEDLY,
THEY CAN WORK IN CONJUNCTION
WITH EACH OTHER.
IS THAT GOING TO GET THE JOB
DONE?
HERE ARE THE FACTS AS WE KNOW
THEM.
CLINTON VIOLATED 18 USC 57.
SPECIAL ACCESS PROGRAMMING
INFORMATION.
SHE DELETED 33,000 EMAILS.
SHE ACID WASHED HER HARD DRIVE
WITH A BLEACH, BUT SHE BEAT THE
CRAP OUT OF HER DEVICES SO THAT
THERE WAS NO RECORD.
IS THAT NOT A VIOLATION OF LAW?
I MEAN, IT IS A SIMPLE.
>> THAT'S WHY IT IS SO
FRUSTRATING.
COMEY SAID THAT'S BECAUSE IT
TRUMPS SUPPOSEDLY SAID MAN, I
HOPE YOU CAN FIND IT IN YOU TO
LET FLYNN GO, THAT THAT IS A
POTENTIAL OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, BUT YET, HE DID NOT
PURSUE ANY OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE FOR THE EMAILS THAT WERE
UNDER CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA.
THOSE WERE THE CRITICAL EMAILS
IN THE HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
AND YET HE DID NOT PURSUE THAT.
SO HOW COULD YOU BE SO ZEALOUS
WITH EVERYONE ASSOCIATED WITH
TRUMPS CAMPAIGN, BUT THEN BEND
OVER BACKWARDS, TIME AND TIME
AGAIN, TO NOT GO AFTER
OBSTRUCTION, OR TO NOT GO AFTER